tú
ah
[Música]
a
desde el pasado fin de semana siete
regiones italianas han sido declaradas
zona roja es decir zonas en las cuales
la circulación del coronavirus es
considerada muy elevada y entonces se
aplican importantes restricciones los
desplazamientos están prohibidos salvo
por razones de salud o trabajo los bares
restaurantes y comercios están cerrados
solo permanecen abiertas las escuelas
primarias prácticamente la mitad de la
población italiana está sometida a estas
restricciones y vive en semi
confinamiento ya que la situación en los
hospitales de varias regiones del país
está al borde del colapso en el último
mes el número de pacientes
hospitalizados en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos se ha multiplicado
por 6 actualmente más de 3400 enfermos
de coronavirus están siendo atendidos en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos y
más de 45.000 personas con kobe ha
muerto en italia desde el inicio de esta
crisis sanitaria
[Música]
la segunda ola golpeó fuertemente a
españa lo que provocó que el pasado 25
de octubre se decretara nuevamente el
estado de alarma que permitía
básicamente a las comunidades autónomas
e imponer nuevas restricciones hagan
pasado el tres semanas y es momento de
evaluar si estas restricciones como el
confinamiento por zonas el toque de
queda o aquí en cataluña por ejemplo el
cierre de bares y restaurantes llegan
sus fotos y es un sí según el presidente
del gobierno español pedro sanz es ya
que la incidencia acumulada en españa se
estabiliza incluso paso por debajo de
los 500 casos por 100.000 habitantes
cuando había llegado el 9 de noviembre
en su punto más alto 529 y ahora algunas
comunidades autónomas como aquí en
cataluña estudian rebajar estas
restricciones el gobierno catalán tiene
que anunciado de aquí a pocos días que
pasará el 23 de noviembre supuestamente
el deber
volver a activar algunos sectores de la
economía como por ejemplo abrir algunas
de gafas de los bares
[Música]
alemania cumple ya dos semanas de lo que
ha sido descrito aquí en el país como un
lock down parcial o esa serie de
restricciones durante el mes de
noviembre que por un lado obligó al
cierre de restaurantes de bares y museos
y por el otro lado permitió que los
colegios y los establecimientos
comerciales permanecieran abiertos las
autoridades se han mostrado
cautelosamente optimistas sobre el
posible impacto que pueda tener esta
serie de restricciones aunque también
han asegurado que todavía es muy pronto
para determinar a ciencia cierta cómo
puede desarrollarse la pandemia en
alemania no solamente en las próximas
semanas sino también en los próximos
meses por el momento es cierto que
alemania continúa registrando números
muy altos de casos de coronavirus
incluso superando los 20 mil casos
diarios y las autoridades alemanas han
estado preparando a la población para lo
que podría ser un invierno muy largo con
unas festividades navideñas muy
limitadas
[Música]